oh c'est pas possible on se fac vie ici
est-ce qu'il est blessé non non non il a
l'habitude
en prenant de l'âge de Jane est-ce que
vous vous préférez physiquement je crois
que là je suis jolie que j'ai pu voir
sur ces films étaient en effet la fille
prodigue je crois que 35 ans c'était pas
mal que c'était nage très jolie pour une
femme aussi parce qu'elle bouscule dans
cette une certitude de ce qu'elle va
devenir ce qui fait qu'elle devient
quelqu'un de très dangereuse pour pour
son mari parce que c'est l'entourage
parce que c'est le c'est comme celui de
faire c'est comme Stephen spagh c'est
tous ces personnes dans les romans
avec une personnage féminin ou son
centre comme ça c'est le moment où vous
imaginez que c'est votre dernière chance
que c'est dans l'amour il y a tout d'un
coup un
détournement de la tête oui absolument
et je trouve ça aussi intéressant que
l'adolescence qui également comme le
petit Nadia communitch quand elle
marchait sur son fil de fer et la grâce
était aussi parce qu'elle était ni
garçon ni fille elle n'avait pas encore
basculé dans le certitude féminine alors
ça la rendait fascinante à nos yeux vous
auriez aimé être un garçon oui
j'aurais adoré
certainement très longtemps
même quoi je crois que j'aurais été très
homosexuel
beau
garçon
mais je trouve mais je trouve plus jolie
dans les vêtements de garçon
je voulais être une frère pour mon frère
parce que je voulais pouvoir faire des
choses comme lui je voulais aller à
l'internat avec lui je m'étaisie pyjamas
ses vêtements c'est des choses de mon
père c'est vrai c'est vrai que je trouve
ça rigolo on parlera tout à l'heure de
vous au théâtre vous êtes beaucoup plus
féminine en fait que l'image qu'on a de
vous parce que fini les jeans
alors ça veut dire que Xavier duranger
qui est cette amour de 35 ans
a décidé qu'il en avait marre de tout le
reste et que lui voulait me faire
il voulait que je sois qu'est-ce qu'il a
dit oh je veux que ça soit sexe
une journée avec vous elle commence un
peu tard dans la matinée Franck
Pelletier et Claude Barnier vous ont
retrouvé chez vous
c'est bien connu Jane Birkin adore la
compagnie elles font devant le chien de
sa fille loup car avec lui ses cinémas à
tous les étages
j'espère oh
pas possible osef
[Musique]
en plus profond d'elle-même Jean Birkin
est en quelque sorte une Alice au pays
des merveilles qui court sans cesse être
débordé si tôt levé elle adore ça
et puis à partir de là c'est d'essayer
de se donner des coups pour pour se
réveiller en mettre en marche pour un
journée qui va finir pour moi à 4h du
matin et par minuit c'est tout je dis
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse les
lunettes parce que je suis aveugle mais
en fait je vois rien s'il faut il faut
que ça soit en braille alors je vais
aller à l'opticien parce que je me suis
assise sur mes lunettes bifocales
non mais je m'en fous tout le temps
c'est parce que les yeux sont trop
agités trop agité mais bien affûté car
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
Jane à l'oeil gourmand avec elle le
lèche vitrine se transforme vite en
partie de plaisir
[Musique]
merci beaucoup au revoir au revoir
et bien aimé bruncher avec sa fifille
dommage mais Jane n'en est pas perdu
pour autant
[Musique]
il est 16h30 Jane rejoint sa famille de
cœur celle du théâtre
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas au meilleur
de sa forme elle a une angine et comme
tous les jours elle caresse ses grigri
anti superstition j'ai des morceaux de
bois plein j'en avais même un dans le
pied que je ne veux pas voulu enlever un
écharde j'ai gardé deux semaines dis
donc super sûr que les trucs marchent
même au pied du mur Jane Birkin conserve
cette grâce et ce sourire qui nous font
tous craquer
[Musique]
mes petits morceaux de bois qui est sur
mon porte-clé c'est un besoin comme ça
d'être protégé par des objets je crois
que ça c'est des ça c'est des conneries
qui sont très très propre au théâtre
c'était métier après tout assez pas
vraiment dangereux dangereux parce qu'il
y a des gens qui font des choses
vraiment dangereux mais c'est vrai que
je retire la pomme alors
c'est seulement dans les lieux qu'il
faut pas alors c'est c'est vrai que oui
les morceaux de bois j'ai attrapé ça
depuis Pierre Dux
[Musique]